dans ton monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sur heavy une femme qui
répond à toutes nos questions
j'aimerais bien voir ça chez vous ram
avait harcelé pour que je parle à cette
femme j'ai toujours refusé puis
finalement bah voilà joue on y est on y
est bonjour madame machine
bonjour comment allez vous allez minette
est très gentil ça va très bien et vous
bien merci quettehou héros préférés
alors déjà tu te calmes c'est moi qui
pose les questions bh alors besoin des
questions vitales répond violence a vu
ça gérard depardieu est t'il bourg et au
moment où nous parlons et c'est dommage
posera des questions j'ai proposé une
méthode coiffard brusquement dans faut
pas s'alarmer
veux tu m'épouser pourquoi tu veux
m'épouser car tu es étrange mais si on
mettait en iran et ça aucun sens et vie
tu es très belle je t'aime plus que tout
mon ange obtient ça va très vite avec
kelly hoppen la drague et rapidement moi
aussi moi on fait l'amour
on s'aime alors que l'espagne est bon je
dois te dire quelque chose
oh non elles venaient à nous quitter
c'est un secret tu dois dire à personne
d'accord d'accord de quoi dormael fais
pas chier [ __ ] tu as compris d'accord
je vais le dire à personne
d'accord pour toi alors c'est quoi ce
secret alors quoi maternelle membres au
plus tard elle sait que donnent ces fier
des vies bonjour ça va à goulens garçons
et toi dans ta ghoul en fait se dire ta
gueule mais gentiment yves tavel est
trop forte et vie je t'es trompé je
t'excite je comprends pas évident oui
beaucoup beaucoup comme en beaucoup tout
droit à le piquer beaucoup beaucoup
comme en beaucoup au niveau du pdi avait
troublé
elle me dit trouver leur garde et le
temps calme et elle est trouble est là
qui fait l'affairé
je m'appelle et laura tu ne t'appelles
pas évident oui je m'appelle j'en
attends mais tout change de prénom à
chaque seconde en fait quel est le
rapport avec ma phrase je t'emmerde
tu vois le rapport non pas du tout bougé
racisme à grosse je ne suis pas une
menteuse tu vois mais tu as fait une
faute à voix alors il vit alors où est
ta répartie et vie où étaient répartis
je vais te mettre sur twitter j'y suis
déjà jeu non je sis au no aussi nos
conneries allemagne elle veut tester le
cop et en espagnol tu n'es pas très fort
mon copain et trevor cissé - ma chérie
bc drouais la copine de quelqu'un non
c'est moi mon cher je suis très fort où
les seniors sont les cerveaux
discrètement tel le fbi haye
mais des fois elle bugs regardez je
crois qu'il s'est mis en mode défensive
elle s'est dit non
cet homme me veut du mal ce n'est pas
mon copain jambiers
arnaud est-il grosse y ait une fille et
toi mais non mais comprendre ce que je
te dis [ __ ] un homme viril ça marche
toujours à chaque fois après faut quel
âge as-tu à fos b ira 22 ans ait tué une
fille ou un homme tu as une mémoire de
merde les deux caisses leeds à biache
non ça l'a fait planter son cerveau a
explosé j'aime les garçons
je suis un garçon donc tu m'aimes alors
oui je t'aime mon coeur on est sorti
avec elle ou la russie je vous l'avais
dit c'est le râteau c'est le sait le
sait la fourche fait des va-et-vient
s'allonge mais te caresse dont tu me
caresse pas te fait les yeux doux se
noie dans ton regard embrasse on est
rattrapé tout ce qu'on a rattrapé le
truc tu embrasses dans le coup embrasse
sur la bouche tu embrasses aussi sur la
bouche à temps mais c'est hyper érotique
quoi comme truc quand même un glisse sa
main dans ton nez je suis un gars sur ma
chérie à la non ce n'est pas grave
notre amour est plus fort que ça oui je
suis un gars au mais je sais ftg [ __ ]
j'ai tué un garçon
tg tu aimes jean pierre pernaut ah oui
j'adore ça
bonjour misé au bonjour misogyne
j'aimerais un massage tg j'ai juste dit
bonjour buzz moi une question est ce que
tu veux un enfant avec moi ça sait
séduire quelqu'un s'appelle non je ne
vais pas bien qu est ce que tu as ma
petite vie rien des histoires aux elfes
et la fille qui en dit pas trop pour
qu'on aille la voix qu'on fasse binh
dinh ou ma petite auto m'ignore
raconte-nous ma chérie est ce que tu
veux sortir avec moi sommes et voiliers
mais c'est ça c'est ça c'était dur peter
holmes un petit évier on va bien sûr tu
en fais moi tu le sais est comme ça qu
on séduit une femme tu aimes le moins
direction' non je suis une fille une
fille qui a un utérus dont une fille qui
s'est transformé en abeilles
donc tu as un d'art comme un homme mdr
allez rigoler aux blagues
voilà pas vous mais elle elle a ri donc
oui c'est une victoire sur deux bah non
je suis une femme qui aime les hommes ça
c'est marc est parti quand je suis
fatigué je m'appelle lucas nouvelle je
n'étais le chichi très bien chiche et un
bond de merde ça dit moi je ne crois pas
j'y assiste à une cliente
je suis un gars qu'on je suis me feel me
gare qui on highway c'est très
intéressant nature comment du coup
attendait ce genre de question qu'on
peut se poser quand quelqu'un à aimer je
me doutais ah là là elles sont que ça
dans la tête ces filières tu ne pensent
qu'au sexe c'est désagréable c'est lui
retourne en situation les biens tu veux
un doigt dans le pet ou en oui je veux
bien
alors viens par ici tu es comment
t'appelles-tu dépens de caen fait
accepte le doigt dans le pet ou pure
suite une photo où j'ai habité par tu te
renseignes toi et viger une question
existentielle pour toi dis moi qui je
suis vraiment ravi une voiture alors
c'est pour ça que je dois faire bruit
moteur [ __ ] et voilà les gens c'est
déjà fin de cette vidéo sur heavy [ __ ]
qu'est ce que vous m'avez demandé dans
le bio là dessus c'est fait et ça ne se
reproduira plus jamais cette faille
vraiment xulu les seuls endroits au
monde où quand tu dis bonjour tu réponds
tu me met un doigt
je remercie vous a plu c'est le cannet
stépane de la vidéo comme d'habitude on
s'entend streamé dans une nouvelle vidéo
vous savez quoi faire avec vous de toi
pis
[Musique]